si les cas qui se veut légiférer sur la
laïcité de l'état aux questions de
retirer le crucifix ou salon bleu parce
qu'il ferait partie du patrimoine un
objet de patrimoine y en ad'autres sida
a soulevé les jo sont pour la petite
histoire c'est le premier ministre
maurice duplessis qui a fait accrocher
en 1936 un crucifix au salon bleu le
lieu des débats le crucifix a été
remplacé en 82 un autre avait aussi été
installée au salon rouge mais il est
disparu en 1968 avec l'abolition du
conseil législatif une sorte de sénat
qu'on avait à québec
on a donc cherché les deux crucifix
disparu s'ils font partie du patrimoine
en tout cas ils ne sont pas dans un
musée
malgré des recherches importantes
l'assemblée nationale n'a retrouvé qu'un
seul crucifix et il était impossible de
savoir avec certitude dans quel salon il
était nous revient que certains époque
après une grande importance accordée à
ce fameux suis ça devient une espèce de
symboles facile pour parler de
patrimoine 6 des pressions qu'ont pu
rapidement figé des choses pour pas
effaroucher nombre une majorité de taxe
est pas là depuis les débuts du
parlementarisme loin là un historien de
l'assemblée nationale a déjà évoqué que
duplessis c'est peut-être respirer du
dictateur benito mussolini qui avait
fait la même chose en italie quelques
années plus tôt si on veut se rappeler
de passer aucun problème mais pourquoi
ne pas le mettre ailleurs dans le dans
le parlement
quand je parle aux gens des autres
cultures ça les arrange toi de voir le
crucifix à l'assemblée nationale
monsieur legault et sérieux par rabat
laïcité la masse est il que pau retirer
le crucifix net en faveur de la
discussion qu'on va entendre les
arguments des autres formations police
saviez vous que la prière au parlement a
été aboli en 1976 le président de la
chambre clément richard d'allégeance
péquiste déclarait c'est par respect
pour les membres de cette assemblée qui
ne sont pas nécessairement tous de la
même dénomination religieuse beaucoup
par des recommandations de la commission
bouchard taylor lorsqu'il est question
d'un consensus sur la laïcité de l'état
et bien leur rapport recommandait le
retrait du crucifix à l'assemblée
nationale si vous voulez retrouver cette
espèce de quête d'authenticité
mais pourquoi pas peindre en vert je
vous rappelle que je
978 les murs de l'assemblée législative
nationale et à anvers passé la tradition
britannique
[Musique]